foreign
people I'm back in studio it's November
17 2021 I'm still Dave Rubin and this is
still the Reuben report direct message
you may be noting that I'm wearing a
very very special shirt and I just want
to say right up top this is not a
political message specifically I have a
friend Brandon who's been struggling
with some stuff lately Brandon I know
you're watching the show right now and I
just want to say that we're with you we
love you and let's go Brandon okay we
know you're gonna get through this and
it's very important that if anyone sees
anyone named Brandon this isn't just
about you if you see a Brandon on the
street you see a Brandon on Twitter on
Facebook you say let's go Brandon and
and you're proud of who you are so I'm
very excited about my new let's go
Brandon T shirt okay we got a big show
for you today I was in Tennessee for a
couple days uh over in Nashville I taped
Candace Owens Show and I taped it
interview with her on her set I just
absolutely adore the girl and she is
just she's one of these people she
stepped into my studio years ago sort of
as just like a little YouTuber who
didn't know exactly what she's doing and
now she is somebody fully changing the
world and in my humble opinion for the
world the world for the better so we're
gonna post that uh in a day or two and
just had a great time in Nashville good
people great food I'm filled with hot
chicken right now I ate so much hot
chicken just absolutely insane and the
daily wire is just building out amazing
facilities over there lots of good stuff
happening and speaking of good stuff
that's happening The Babylon bee these
guys just do great work like basically
they're doing satire right like where
SNL live should be doing satire The
Babylon B actually does it right and I
was chosen to do a little voice over
work in the Babylon bees newest Cartoon
about the Ghostbusters we're gonna play
about 45 seconds of it for you and the
full thing you can see on the Babylon B
YouTube channel do you have a narrow
iterative problem are you tired of dead
people exposing the flaws of your
political beliefs then call us we'll
take care of any ghost that doesn't fit
your agenda
help me
I got the Pfizer vaccine and then the
blood clot exploded my heart vaccines
are 100 safe and effective blaster
vaccines are 100 safe and effective
blast her that was 10 takes it took me
uh there it's great video you can check
them out over on the The Babylon B
YouTube channel as I said and if you
didn't notice yes that was uh Glenn Beck
that was Michael malice and they had a
couple other great people in there so do
check it out uh today we got a bunch of
good stories I'm psyched to be in studio
and I sense we're starting to get some
wins people uh first off Jedediah abila
who was on this show just a couple weeks
ago talking about why she was not
vaccinated you may remember she was a
former co-host of the view I guess she
couldn't take it over there with those
harping shrews anymore she left the view
well they brought her back they did not
let her in studio she had to do it over
Skype and there's an extraordinary
exchange between her and Joy Behar and
some of the other ladies of the view and
we're going to play it for you because
it's just worth watching and you know
I've been saying to you guys that I
don't want to do covid stories that are
just adding to the madness more bad
stuff about covid more idiots locked
down other people wearing 87 masks like
I don't want to do that what I do want
to do is highlight the people that are
fighting and Jedediah won the internet
yesterday and we're going to show you
that then we've got some stuff just
generally on what the Democrats are
doing related to climate policy and if
you think anything that they're doing is
related to saving the climate if you
think that these buffoons who couldn't
balance a budget who don't know that
boys are different than girls and the
rest of it if you think that any of
these ridiculous policies they're that
they're bringing in have anything to do
with climate you're very mistaken we're
going to show you some examples of that
and then uh there were some great great
great great great great that's a lot of
greats great news this morning we saw
this literally a minute before we
started uh the daily wire
you know they got involved in this
lawsuit against the Biden Administration
uh relative to the vaccine mandates we
got some good news on that front and Ron
DeSantis is fighting he's fighting
vaccine mandates too so we're given good
news today people I'm feeling good I'm
caffeinated and I just want to dedicate
the show to my friend my good friend
Brandon let's go man you're doing it
let's go Brandon before we get to any of
that though I want to talk to you guys
about Cozy Earth you know one of the
best things about being filmed from the
way stuff is that I can look like
business on top while being super comfy
below it's true for those of you who've
been working from home and participating
in multiple Zoom meetings over the past
year you know exactly what I mean that's
why no gift will be more appreciated
this holiday season than cozy Earth
sheets pajamas or loungewear I really
like their sweats I seriously dig them
they're soft and smooth and they're
comfortable I was wearing them last
night and that's because they're made
from super soft viscose from highly
sustainable bamboo cozier's bedding and
loungewear are also temperature
regulating so you'll sleep comfortably
year round it's no wonder that cozy
Earth has become the bedding of choice
for interior designers and celebrities
cozy Earth is so confident that that
you'll love their products that you can
try anything risk-free for a hundred
night trial if you don't love it return
it with 100 days for free so this
holiday season give the gift that will
be appreciated every single night cozy
Earth bedding and loungewear and now my
audience can save 35 on cozy Earth
bedding and loungewear start your
holiday shopping early go to
cozyearth.com enter promo code Dave and
save 35 all right that's 35 off at
cozyearth.com promo code Dave cozier.com
and now back to me we should have taken
a picture I was in the sweatpants last
night like they're soft and lovely and I
fell asleep on the couch watching
Seinfeld a perfect day indeed okay let's
jump right into it so Jedediah who again
I had on the show a couple weeks ago
she's really just become sort of an
All-Star insanity and I love promoting
people that are actually fighting the
machine and she was once part of the
machine she was a co-host on The View I
don't know exactly why she didn't remain
a coast I'm guessing she probably just
couldn't take it much like Megan McCain
just couldn't take it anymore it's very
hard to be an outsider on a show called
The View which was set up to show
different viewpoints of different women
but has become you know a major Echo
chamber anyway they brought her back
they didn't let her in studio we're
going to play you about a minute and a
half clip here and just listen even to
the tone with which Joy Behar uses as
she introduces Jedediah okay Jen so
let's discuss let's address the elephant
in the room because you were supposed to
join you were supposed to join Us in the
studios weeks ago but you couldn't
because ABC has a very strict policy you
can't get into this building unless
you're fully vaccinated everybody in
this room knows that and is vaccinated
but you made a conscious decision not to
get the vaccine now the CDC says a
person is 10 times less likely to be
hospitalized from covid and 11 times
less likely to die if they've gotten the
vaccine okay so why didn't you get it
I have a medical exemption to the
vaccine that's been written by my
infectious disease vaccinated specialist
in New York City that's been co-signed
by three other doctors I'm not a
candidate for this vaccine I also have
Sky High multi-tiered multi-faceted
natural immunity very very high that has
also been proven it has been shown and
it is substantiated by letters from
these doctors so for me personally this
vaccine poses a greater risk than a
benefit I'm also not a risk to any of
you I know there's been a lot of debate
about that but I have these doctors
who've gone on record with that as well
so my point about all of this is that I
am not anti-vaxx what I really want is
for people to make these decisions for
themselves I want every one of you to
sit with your family members to sit with
your trusted doctors and to say what is
the best decision for me however I do
oppose mandates I oppose them on the
fact that let's look at the science this
is a vaccine that was created to prevent
severity of disease and to prevent
hospitalizations now we can have a whole
debate on that in itself but the vaccine
does not prevent you from getting
coveted and does not prevent you from
transmitting my goodness
so come on
you don't have to listen to me on that
you don't have to listen to me you can
listen to the director of the CDC you
can look at the cdc's website that is
why masks were reinstated for people who
were vaccinated because they said and
they admitted they came out and said
this for this Delta variant transmission
is going to be a thing for vaccinated
I am prioritizing my health and people
talk about the commons
we're not prioritizing your own health
man there is so much good there and
Jedediah if you're watching I just want
to say you are an absolute All-Star you
just leveled up into the game you were
part of the machine and now you're
fighting the machine that's exactly what
we need I want to go over a couple of
the bullet points of the things that she
says as Joy is completely dismissing her
she says that she has a medical
exemption so she's not a candidate and
she's worked this through with her
doctors she has Sky High natural
immunity she says she has a letter to
prove it she says she's not a risk to
them because of this natural immunity
and she says she's not anti-backs right
she's anti-mandate she then says that
everyone should make a decision for
themselves if you go back into that part
that's the part that it sounded like
Whoopi burped and then um uh she says
that this is where it really got good
she says the vaccine does not prevent uh
people from getting covered or
transmitting covid we all know this to
be true right now right like Jen saki
had covid two weeks ago she was
obviously vaccinated everyone that I
know that's gotten coveted in the last
two months has been vaccinated I
literally don't know anyone no no but I
will be completely truthful as I try to
be on the show my friend Dennis Prager
did get covered while he was unvaxed and
took all sorts of stuff and he was fine
a few days later this is a guy who is I
love Dennis but he's a little overweight
and smoke cigars all the time and he's
in his 70s but he was 100 okay but
everyone else that I know that has
gotten coveted over the last couple
months has gotten the vaccine so we know
what she said is true and then she said
uh you can once you have the vaccine you
can still transmit it well we know that
is true as well that's where they
started groaning and joy said oh you've
been hanging out with those Fox News
people too much in the audience a bunch
of seals
like it's these people are just
ridiculous then at the end there oh you
know you don't care about people in
effect is what the other one that's
Sunny host and what she was saying you
know you have to care about people more
it's like if the vaccine works then
you'd let her on the set and she has
natural immunity and you'd all be
sitting there and there would be notice
because they all know it they're just
lying like they're just lying I don't
know I really wish that I knew what
happened to Joy Behar I used to adore
her when when I was a good decent
liberal and I lived on the upper west
side of Manhattan and I would see Joy
all the time and I lived right near the
view Studios and we'd chat and I chat
with her husband and she pet my dog and
we talk about stuff she was a you may
not agree with her politics but she was
like a decent liberal right and she just
lost her mind and where were the fact
Checkers on this clip like if we're to
believe that the fact Checkers are
always supposed to fact check things and
these are very important facts it's like
Jedediah said the truth Joy lied Joy
lied the audience applauded it and
that's what I always talk about this
Chasm between reality and what
mainstream shows you so if you have a
whole bunch let's say I don't know and
I've been to the view many times I don't
know how many people they have in the
audience now but I would say usually
it's about 200 people I don't know if
they've limited that now but if you have
200 people in that audience who are all
vaccinated and joy implies that oh no
you can't get coveted if you're
vaccinated you can't get it and you
can't transmit it it's like they're all
applauding it well she's lying and then
they don't know that they're possibly
transmitting it to each other and
everything else
we got some work to do but I think we're
going to do it that brings me to a
fabulous story that I have to tell you
about one man fighting the system and
that man is sitting in this studio right
now and that man is not me in this case
but my producer Michael who is within
the illegal six feet of me right now I'd
say we've got a cool four feet between
us right now uh he was coming with me
he's my producer so he was coming to
Nashville
to do the Canada show with me and meet
their people and everything and he
wanted to get a new shirt for this
adventure that we would be on and I'd
like to say that the Reuben Port pays
decently so the guy can afford a decent
shirt he goes to Bloomingdale's and he's
a good man he's a man who does not want
to upset you know the average person so
he puts on his mask to go in the store
they will not let him in without the
mask he puts on his mask to go in the
store he shops for how long did you shop
for about 30 minutes he shopped in
Bloomingdale's and he found a shirt
found a shirt that he liked how much was
the shirt
a hundred dollars he was going to buy a
shirt for a hundred dollars this is not
a gap throwaway t-shirt this is
Bloomingdale's nice button down
button down do you want what brand what
oh you told me uh All Saints right a
hundred dollar All Saints shirt
Bloomingdale's he goes he takes the
shirt did you try on the shirt you tried
I mean you did everything you could do
when you're buying a shirt he then takes
the shirt to the cash register and the
woman at the register asks to see his
vaccine passport so Michael like a same
decent citizen trying to make sense of
the world said you know I don't think
that I should have to show you my
medical records to buy this lovely All
Saints shirt and they then called over a
manager is that correct they called over
a manager the manager confirmed that
they would not sell him the shirt unless
he showed them his private medical
records
so Michael did not leave with the shirt
and had to wear his old ratty shirt no
it's a nice shirt it's perfectly fine
shirt uh but do you see how insane this
is they let him in he shopped
for a half hour spread his germs all
over the All Saints and the theory give
me another brand the uh give me a brand
give me a brand uh what is a brand that
they have it Bloomingdale's I got two
guys don't come on give me something All
Saints they got Theory they got uh Vince
they got Vince over there at uh
Bloomingdale's okay
um spread his germs all over the place
they let him in and then only when he's
trying to leave ma'am can I leave this
store can I give you money can we
exchange Commerce can we do the thing
that is the lifeblood of human society
no sorry you can't do that
that's how stupid this whole thing is I
gotta get the hell out of this town you
guys with me what do you think all right
all right let's see what happens guys
let's talk about relief man real quick
you know during the holidays many of us
eat until we're stuffed like turkeys and
we feel sick we've all experienced that
horrible feeling whether it's the result
of one too many after a night out with
the friends or from the anxiety of
accidentally landing on CNN while
channel surfing
not sure can ruin a day and in the most
severe cases it can make us unable to
function for those of you who can relate
you've got to check out relief band
relief band's the number one FDA cleared
anti-nausea wristband that's been
clinically proven to relieve and prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness chemotherapy
and so much more the product is 100 drug
free non-drowsy and provides all natural
relief with zero side effects for as
long as needed relief man stimulates a
nerve in the wrist that travels to the
part of the brain the brain that
controls nausea then it blocks the
signal your brain is sending to your
stomach telling you that you're sick for
those of you who want to enjoy being
active without the added Anxiety Relief
band just released its newest model
relief band sport the sport is
waterproof features interchangeable
bands and has an extended battery life
as the holiday season quickly approaches
there's never been a better time to give
the gift of relief right now relief band
has an exclusive offer just for my
audience
if you go to reliefband.com and you use
promo code Reuben you'll receive 20 off
plus free shipping and a no quick no
questions asked 30-day money-back
guarantee so head over to reliefband.com
and use my promo code Reuben for 20 off
plus free shipping I should add by the
way to the little Bloomingdale's ordeal
that Michael uh went through that I did
buy the let's go Brandon t-shirts for my
entire team and they have the t-shirts
and you know you you'll be okay next
time we go to daily wire all right let's
talk a little bit about climate because
it's become fairly clear to anyone
paying attention that as we shift out of
covid mania the system the machine is
going to need more craziness to further
lock down further control us further
figure out ways to manipulate us further
figure out ways to keep us scared and
angry and everything else and I do sense
and I really do that the covid thing is
starting
to uh I would say close up like they're
not going to stop with the
fear-mongering and everything else but I
think a lot of people are finally just
moving on I really believe it so they've
got to figure out something else because
they can't have you walking around not
in fear just thinking straight and
looking around and seeing the world
around you and making individual
thoughts and choices for yourself they
can't have that right so they got to
keep the Kobe thing going so here's some
video of Jen saki she is back after she
got coveted and had to take about 10
days off she was vaccinated for covet
somehow got covered don't tell Joy Behar
that would be very upsetting uh and I
think what saki says here kind of lends
itself to the way that they are going to
uh increase the fear take a look just be
clear I know that's been a criticism so
that's why I said that not an accurate
one look our view is that the rise in
gas prices over the long term makes it
an even stronger case for doubling down
our investment and our focus on clean
energy options so that we are not
relying on uh the fluctuations and OPEC
and their willingness to put more Supply
and meet the demands in the market
man it's so dangerous what she said
right there if you really listen to what
she's saying she's basically going yeah
gas prices are rising so we're gonna
have to do more of our green stuff our
recycling stuff our renewable stuff now
I'm not against Green things I'm not
against uh doing all sorts of things
related to say nuclear power I know that
scares these people even though it's
deeply deeply safe and we now know that
and they're trying to close all these
nuclear power plants but what she's
saying is as gas prices rise we're gonna
have to do more of all that stuff that
we've been trying to push down your
throats with Bill back better and our
crazy bills and lunatic AOC and
everything else so wouldn't it behoove
them then to actually
raise gas prices wouldn't if you really
believe that you wanted to transfer
everybody over to green power and the
green New Deal and their green
dystopia although they believe it's a
Utopia wouldn't you then do everything
you could to make gas as expensive as
possible wouldn't you do everything you
could to destroy the economy if you're
really saying we have to build back
better we have to completely change
things and by the way this is what
they're saying right they're telling us
that what an opportunity there is after
kovid to really look at how we do
everything in America and fundamentally
change things and you silly silly decent
liberals the last 20 of you that thought
that old Joe Biden was going to stop it
he has ushered it in more than
absolutely anyone else so it would
actually benefit the people who want us
to get to this green thing that will
never really work and is going to cause
so many problems and cause actually all
sorts of uh depression for uh poor or
people I discussed that with Jordan
Peterson like the best way to help poor
people is through cheaper energy
resources right but that's not really
what they're interested in check out my
interview with Jordan Peterson from last
week if you want to get a little bit
more on that but basically she's telling
you the part that she's not supposed to
tell you we're happy when gas prices go
up and perhaps we would do everything we
could to make gas prices go up and by
the way we're kind of happy when the
supply chain gets screwed up because
then that kind of proves that capitalism
doesn't really work so we'll have to
figure out ways to maybe socialize uh
the system right we'll have to make sure
that our infrastructure system has far
more government involvement and much
less capitalist competition that would
make sense so they're telling you what
they're doing and if you don't think
that's enough we saw this video over the
weekend I saw this one
this is the Minister of environment and
climate change of Canada you know we've
been going through this big climate
conference these people all fly in their
private jets across the world most of
them like Barack Obama live in 11
million dollar Estates in Martha's
Vineyard right on the water you'd think
they'd move Inland but they don't it's
very weird uh well Stephen Bilbo who is
the Minister of environment and climate
change in Canada uh had a something very
interesting to say about climate and I
think you'll see the intersectional
nature of this stupidity Mr chair I
would like to say that Canada strongly
support strong languages on the rights
of indigenous peoples and the inclusion
of their traditional knowledge in in the
fight against climate change as well as
the protection of human rights as part
of this text thank you very much Mr
Speaker
okay I have no problem with indigenous
people right that's just fine if you
your people came from a certain place
and you're still there and you're doing
your thing but do you see by the way
they combine all of these things climate
change has absolutely nothing to do with
indigenous people he talks about the
traditional knowledge of indigenous
people to fight climate change is there
something that an indigenous person by
the bare birth knows more about climate
change than say the average scientist
who perhaps has been studying it who
maybe didn't come from the place that
they live on now like most of us and
most of our families and most of our
history most of man's history is a
history of people moving all over the
world in all sorts of Wars have been
fought and civilizations have grown and
civilizations have crumbled like is
there anything is there anything he says
the traditional knowledge of indigenous
people
it's a completely nonsensical statement
but they love it they love it again they
just clap on oh my God indigenous people
we like indigenous people traditional
knowledge we like traditional knowledge
somehow it's against capitalism we like
being against capitalism
these people are so boring anyway I tell
you all of this just to say uh start
watching out for this the next thing
that's coming is the climate stuff there
will be climate lockdowns they will not
want cars on the road they will tell you
to stay in your house and use less heat
when it's cold and use less air
conditioning with it when it's hot and a
whole bunch of other stuff it's just on
the way I'm gonna fight it why not
speaking of people that are fighting you
know this Ron DeSantis guy down in
Florida who's basically saving the Union
by himself he is basically the One Man
Standing Up Against the Machine at least
at a political level and I'm being
slightly sarcastic there there obviously
are a bunch of other Republicans doing
it including Greg Abbott in Texas and
Ted Cruz and Rand Paul and now Glenn
Younkin and there are a bunch more but
DeSantis is sort of like the poster boy
to how to stand up to our authoritarian
and overreaching federal government
right now and he's doing it relentlessly
in every day and pretty much in every
facet of his job he's doing it well
DeSantis had this to say about the OSHA
vaccine mandate from the Biden
Administration I do this going forward
so this is just the tip of the iceberg
it's going to get more restrictive
there's going to be more power brought
to bear uh going forward if we don't
stand up now
um and fight back I just think people
are so sick of constantly being bossed
around restricted mandated all these
different things we've had enough of it
and we want people to be able to make
their own decisions and so so it is
important to stand up for people's
individual ability to make decisions for
themselves I also think it's just the
constitutionality is very significant
the individual freedom very significant
but put those even aside what's the
practice result of this the Practical
result of this is this going to
exacerbate a lot of the existing
problems that we're seeing with the
economy particularly as it rates relates
to the supply chain the ability to get
Goods to Market this is not going to
help the inflation that we've seen in
the economy I could tell you that is
definitely not going to help making sure
that that this the the shelves are
stocked and stores around this country
preach brother preach like that is right
he makes the clear philosophical
arguments related to our constitution
related to what our rights are and
individual rights and what the
government's supposed to do and then I
love how he shifted to the Practical
part hey people if you start firing all
of these people or you demand that these
people do think do certain things to
their bodies because you so wish it
whether it has anything to do with
science or not you might do other things
such as have a creation of more supply
chain problems such as inflation like
all of the stuff that's happening right
in front of our eyes it might have a
little bit to do with people who are
stepping away from their jobs or being
fired because they don't want the
government to force them to make a
medical decision so DeSantis is doing an
absolutely great job like that's the
type of politician you want who says hey
here's how we're governed right here's
how we're governed here's what the laws
say and how does that then translate
into the real world that is exactly what
he did there oh that is exactly what he
did there
um and and that's what you want out of a
out of an elected official uh and then
we just saw this literally one minute
before the show uh Ben Shapiro just
tweeted this out because as you guys may
know uh the daily wire has been leading
the lawsuit uh my friend harmeet Dylan
who's a former guest on the show as well
has been the lead lawyer on this uh
against the Biden Administration vaccine
mandates and here's a two-part tweet
from Ben Shapiro breaking OSHA has
suspended implementation and enforcement
of Biden's unconstitutional vax mandate
for private sector employers pending the
outcome of litigation against the daily
wire and others good this means that if
you're a private sector employer who has
been working to comply with Biden's
mandate under threat of government
coercion stop there is no mandate
currently in effect for you don't make
it easy for them fight so basically the
courts have said you do not have a right
to do this we're going to look at the
case and after we look at the case we'll
make a decision it is my fervent belief
and obviously Ben's as well in Army
Dillons and many other people and all
Freedom loving people that the
government will lose this case that the
courts will will stand up and say no
just because you have a certain amount
of employees you have no right to force
them to do anything with their bodies
that they don't want to do and of course
on top of everything else you know the
hundred or thousand or 500 or 862 person
mandate like this idea that oh there's a
certain amount of people who work at
your company so you have to do it it's
completely arbitrary and ridiculous I do
sit in a relatively small room with two
other people why aren't they forcing me
not to give you freaks any ideas so this
is great news and that's why I wanted to
cover it because I'm going to cover the
good news and make sure that you are
armed with the good news and the truth
because if we do that that is how we
will beat this thing I am not here to
lie to you like Joy Behar oh you've been
watching too much Fox News you think if
you're vaccinated you can transmit and
get covered
guys part three oh you know what we'll
do a couple comments because you know
we're doing the uh the live chat over at
reubenreport.locals.com I've got Helen
in there she sends me your comments live
couple comments before we got at it get
out of here Bob says he has a man crush
on DeSantis
not that there's anything wrong with
that great Bob like to hear it like to
hear it uh Dax says the view should now
be called the singular view that's the
point you know I remember watching The
View The View used to be a great show
actually the Hot Topics portion of the
view you know now we're used to
everybody on YouTube and all these shows
arguing and having people on and having
conversations but the view was really
the first show that was doing it live on
television with a bunch of women and if
you if you go back you can probably find
this on YouTube somewhere if you go back
to the original opening of the view it
was Barbara Walters and she in the show
opening that they would air every day as
the show would begin it would be her
saying something like you know I'm
Barbara Walters and I wanted different
women of different walks of life of
different ages and different beliefs to
sit down and talk about things and
that's why I created The View and then
they'd show Joy Behar and Meredith
Pierre and whatever
and the point was they could argue they
could have these differences of opinion
and not destroy each other and yes it
has now become the singular view for
sure uh Patrick says support indigenous
people replace Twitter with smoke
signals that would be
wouldn't that be refreshing wouldn't
that be refreshing I have a feeling my
day is on Twitter are coming to a close
I'm not exactly sure when I've been
hinting at it for a while but like I
think I've sort of become popular enough
enough people know me it's just such a
freaking headache over there uh that
maybe I'll just wrap it up soon enough
uh guys part three of my interview with
Andrew Clavin I love Andrew I've
mentioned the daily wire a lot today uh
Andrew is obviously one of the hosts of
The Daily wire he is an author uh his
new book Not A Christmas Story What's
the title of the book
When Christmas Comes thank you Connor uh
is out right now he's a wonderful
novelist and and writes mystery books
and all sorts of things and he's just a
great guy just a great guy part three is
up right now on YouTube the full thing
is up ad free of course at
reubenreport.locals.com and my interview
my sit down with Candace Owens we just
sat in her Studio it was so awesome
because she's got a huge crew like
they're they're pouring tons of money
into this and I've just so watched her
just become who she's supposed to be and
we did it in her Studio sort of off the
set a little bit it was really cool uh
the full interview will be coming to
YouTube tomorrow but it is up on uh is
it up on locals right now it will be up
foreign clip one will be on YouTube
tomorrow and the full will be on locals
tomorrow so you can go to
reubenreport.com.locos no Reuben report
at locals.com a lot of information
flying at me today uh all right I
enjoyed Today's show how do you feel
about it thumbs up how do you feel about
it thumbs up all right people see ya